COMPREHENSIVE IMPEACHMENT
COVERAGE YOU WILL FIND
ANYWHERE.
TO MAKE SENSE OF IT ALL I'LL
BE JOINED BY A FANTASTIC
LINEUP MARSHA BLACKBURN, JASON
CHASE OATES AND KENNEDY.
THE CONSTITUTION GIVES
CONGRESS THE POWER TO REMOVE A
PRESIDENT BEFORE THEIR TERM IS
UP.
THEY SAID HE COMMITTED
TREASON, BRIBERY OR OTHER HIGH
CRIMES OF MISDEMEANOR.
IT STARTS WITH AN
INVESTIGATION, HEARING AND THE
VOTE IS TAKEN.
IF THE MAJORITY OF THE HOUSE
AGREES TO RESOLUTION CALLED
ARTICLES OF IMPEACHMENT THE
PRESIDENT IS TECHNICALLY
IMPEACHED, SOMETHING THAT HAS
HAPPENED TO TWO PRESIDENTS.
JOHNSON AND BILL CLINTON.
BUT, BEING IMPEACHED DOESN'T
MEAN THE PRESIDENT IS
IMMEDIATELY REMOVED FROM
OFFICE.
THINK OF IT AS AN INDICTMENT.
WHAT HAPPENS NEXT IS THE
TRIAL.
THAT TAKES PLACE IN THE SENATE
PRESIDED BY CHIEF JUSTICE OF
THE SUPREME COURT.
THE HOUSE MANAGES TO MAKE HIS
CASE AND THE PRESIDENT HAS A
LEGAL TEAM TO MAKE HIS.
THE SENATE VOTES AND NEEDS A
TWO THIRDS MAJORITY TO CONVICT
AND REMOVE THE PRESIDENT FROM
OFFICE.
WE WILL GET TO THAT LATER WITH
SENATOR BLACKBURN, ONE OF THE
HUNDRED PEOPLE ON THE STREET.
JUST TO BE CLEAR THERE ARE
CURRENTLY 47 SENATE DEMOCRATS
THAT WOULD TAKE AT LEAST 20
REPUBLICAN VOTES TO REMOVE THE
PRESIDENT FROM OFFICE.
OKAY.
THAT'S THE OFFICIAL PROCESS.
BUT WHAT IS ALL THIS REALLY
ABOUT?
THERE IS A MILE ANGELOU QUOTE
MY ANGELO QUOTE.
WHEN SOMEONE SHOWS YOU WHO
THEY ARE, BELIEVE THEM THE
FIRST TIME.
ALL RIGHT THEN,.
>> IMPEACHED 45 IF YOU'RE
ASKING IF I WOULD VOTE TO
IMPEACH THIS PRESIDENT, THE
ANSWER IS YES.
>> I SAY IMPEACHMENT,
IMPEACHMENT, IMPEACHMENT.
>> WORKING TO GO IN THERE.
[INAUDIBLE]
>> THEY BEEN WANTING TO
IMPEACH TRUMP FROM PRACTICALLY
THE MOMENT HE WAS ELECTED.
ON TUESDAY AFTERNOON NANCY
PELOSI JUMPED ON THE BANDWAGON
TO TRY TO BRING SOME
CONSTITUTIONAL LEGITIMACY BUT
SHE LET SLIP THE REAL
MOTIVATION EARLIER THAT DAY.
>> WHAT'S MORE SERIOUS IS THAT
HE CAN'T WIN.
THERE YOU HAVE IT, THE MOST
SERIOUS THING IS STOPPING
DONALD TRUMP.
IT'S NOT ABOUT THE
CONSTITUTION IT'S ABOUT
RETRIBUTION.
THEY HATE HIM AND CAN'T
BELIEVE HE ONE AND THEY ARE
WORRIED HE WILL WIN AGAIN.
THEY LECTURE US BUT THEY ARE
THE ONES WHO WANT TO USE
NONDEMOCRATIC MEANS TO GET RID
OF THE DEMOCRATICALLY ELECTED
PRESIDENT.
THIS UKRAINE STORY IS JUST THE
LATEST PRETEXT.
FIRST IT WAS COLLUSION AND
OBSTRUCTION AND WHEN THAT
DIDN'T WORK THEY GAVE UP FOR A
FEW WEEKS.
OH NO, THEY THOUGHT WE MIGHT
HAVE TO TRY TO BEAT HIM IN AN
ACTUAL ELECTION, BUT THEN,
JUST IN THE NICK OF TIME A
WHISTLEBLOWER CAME ALONG AND
BOY WERE THEY EXCITED.
JACKIE SPEAR LAST WEEK, SHE'S
ON THE IMPEACHMENT COMMITTEE.
>> FRANKLY, THIS TURNED OUT TO
BE A GIFT BECAUSE IT IS SO
CLEAR, SO BLATANT AND SO
CORRUPT.
>> A GIFT.
SO MUCH FOR NANCY PELOSI'S BS
ABOUT HOW SAD THIS ALL IS.
NOW, ABOUT THAT WHISTLEBLOWER
WHO GAVE THE DEMOCRATS THEIR
GIFT, THE NEW YORK TIMES
REPORTED LAST WEEK THAT HE IS
A CIA BUREAUCRAT.
LET ME REMIND YOU OF ANOTHER
ANONYMOUS BUREAUCRAT WHO MADE
A SPLASH ABOUT A YEAR AGO.
WE KNOW BECAUSE THEY TOLD US
THAT THERE'S AN ORGANIZED
GROUP OF UNELECTED OFFICIALS
ACTIVELY PLOTTING AGAINST THE
ELECTED PRESIDENT THERE
SUPPOSED TO SERVE.
WE ALSO KNOW THIS LATEST
ATTEMPT TO OVERTURN THE 2016
ELECTION WAS PUT INTO MOTION
TO THE DEMOCRATS WERE GIVING
UP ON THE MUELLER REPORT AS A
BASIS FOR IMPEACHMENT AND
ACCORDING TO AN INDEPENDENT
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT MEMO THIS
WHISTLEBLOWER IS AN ANTI-
TRUMP PART IS ON.
HIS DEFENDANTS I TRUST HIM
BECAUSE HE FOLLOWED THE
PROCESS, BUT THAT'S NOT TRUE,
HE FOLLOWED THE RIGHT PROCESS
UNTIL HIS CLAIM WAS REJECTED.
THEN IT LEAKED TO THE PRESS.
READ THE DOCUMENT HE WROTE.
HE COMES ACROSS AS WHAT HE IS,
A POMPOUS, ARROGANT BUREAUCRAT
WHO IS HORRIFIED BY THE IDEA
THAT A POLITICAL OUTSIDER
COULD BARGE INTO HIS COZY
RULING ELITE SNOOTY
ESTABLISHMENT AND SAY IT'S
OUTRAGEOUS TO DISPARAGE THIS
PERSON.
THAT WOULD HAVE NEVER HAPPENED
UNDER OBAMA.
CAN YOU IMAGINE?
WELL YES, IF YOUR NAME IS
EDWARD SNOWDEN.
WHEN A WHISTLEBLOWER
EMBARRASSES OBAMA HE'S
VILIFIED BUT IF HE HELPS THEM
GET TRUMP, HE'S.
[INAUDIBLE]
WHAT HYPOCRITES.
ANY JOURNALIST WHO
UNCRITICALLY ACCEPTS THE
CLAIMS OF THIS WHISTLEBLOWER
IS ALLOWING THEIR CONTEMPT FOR
TRUMP TO DESTROY THEIR
JUDGMENT.
NOW, WHAT ABOUT THE ALLEGED
WRONGDOING, THE MOST SERIOUS
CLAIM IS THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
WITHHELD U.S. MILITARY AID AS
A QUID PRO QUO FOR UKRAINE TO
INVESTIGATE JOE BIDEN.
THE MEDIA HAS PUT OUT WHAT
THEY CALL A DAMNING TIMELINE.
THE CALL WITH THE UKRAINIAN
PRESIDENT HAPPENED JULY 25.
ON AUGUST 12, THE
WHISTLEBLOWER FILED THEIR
COMPLAINT.
AT THE END OF AUGUST,
PRESIDENT TRUMP EFFECTIVELY
PUT A HOLD ON MILITARY AID
MONEY.
ON SEPTEMBER 1 THE VP MET WITH
THE UKRAINIAN LEADER.
EIGHT DAYS LATER, HOUSE
COMMITTEES STARTED
INVESTIGATING AND BY SEPTEMBER
12, RIGHT AFTER ADAM SCHIFF
STARTED TO ASK QUESTIONS ABOUT
THE COMPLAINTS, THE AID WAS
LIFTED.
>> THERE CLAIMING TRUMP ONLY
RELEASE THE AID ONCE HE KNEW
CONGRESS WAS INVESTIGATING.
THERE'S JUST ONE PROBLEM WITH
THAT TIMELINE.
IT LEAVES OUT TWO CRUCIAL
FACTS AND ONE CRUCIAL STEP.
FIRST FACT, EVERYONE KNOWS
TRUMP IS AN AIDE SKEPTIC.
HOLDING UP AID TO UKRAINE IS
TOTALLY CONSISTENT TO HIS
POLICY POSITION WITH WHAT HE
SAID REPEATEDLY TO OTHER WORLD
LEADERS AND TO THE PRESIDENT
OF UKRAINE ON THAT NOW FAMOUS
PHONE CALL.
SECOND FACT AS KEN REPORTED,
UKRAINE DIDN'T EVEN KNOW THE
AID WAS BEING HELD UP UNTIL A
MONTH AFTER THAT CALL.
HOW ON EARTH COULD YOU HAVE A
QUID PRO QUO WHEN ONE SIDE
DOESN'T EVEN KNOW ABOUT IT.
HERE'S HOW PRESIDENT TRUMP
EXPLAINED.
>> CAN YOU EXPLAIN WHY AID TO
UKRAINE WAS STOPPED.
>> BECAUSE I THINK ANOTHER
COUNTRY SHOULD BE PAYING.
WHY IS THE UNITED STATES THE
ONLY ONE PAYING TO UKRAINE I
SAID HOLD IT UP AND LET'S GET
OTHER PEOPLE TO PAY.
>> AND NOW WE HAVE
CORROBORATION IN THE FORM OF
SENATOR ROB PORTMAN.
>> I CALLED THE PRESIDENT
BECAUSE WE WERE GETTING TO THE
POINT WHERE THE FUNDS HAD TO
BE RELEASED.
THE PRESIDENT WAS VERY CLEAR
WITH ME, HE ONLY RAISED ONE
ISSUE AND THAT ISSUE ONLY AND
THAT WAS ABOUT THE EUROPEANS
NOT DOING ENOUGH.
I DON'T DISAGREE WITH HIM ON
THAT.
WE WERE AT THE POINT WHERE WE
HAD TO OBLIGATE THE FUNDS SO
THEY CAN BE EFFECTIVE SO WE
NEEDED TO GET THE MONEY GOING,
BUT I THINK THE PRESIDENT WAS
INTERESTED IN USING THE FUNDS
AS LEVERAGE TO TRY TO GET THE
EUROPEANS TO DO MORE.
>> SO HERE'S THE CRUCIAL STEP
LEFT OUT OF THE ESTABLISHMENT
TIMELINE.
ON THE 11th OF SEPTEMBER ROB
PORTMAN CALLED THE PRESIDENT.
LATER THAT DAY THE AID IS
RELEASED.
IT GOT NOTHING TO DO WITH
INVESTIGATING JOE BIDEN.
WHEN SUPPOSEDLY SERIOUS AND
IMPARTIAL JOURNALISTS FAIL TO
PROVIDE THOSE DETAILS BECAUSE
THEY EXONERATE THE PRESIDENT
ON THE QUID PRO QUO CHARGE,
THEY ARE DELIBERATELY
MISLEADING YOU.
THE WALL STREET JOURNAL HAD IT
RIGHT, THE CONVERSATION WAS
LESS THAN PROMOTED BY THE
PRESS.
GOOD LUCK TO PERSUADE
AMERICANS THIS IS AN
IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE.
ON TO THE SECOND CLAIM THAT
THE PRESIDENT INVITED A
FOREIGN GOVERNMENT TO
INTERFERE IN OUR ELECTION.
NOW, LET'S NOT BE NAI
NOW, LET'S NOT BE NAÏVE.
YOU THINK PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
THE FIRST AMERICAN LEADER TO
BRING DOMESTIC POLITICAL
CONCERN INTO THE RELATIONSHIP
OF ANOTHER COUNTRY?
AT THE END OF THEIR FIRST
MEETING BARACK OBAMA LEANED
OVER TO MY OLD BOSS DAVID
CAMERON LIKE A MOB BOSS TOLD
HIM WHAT SIDE HE SHOULD BE ON
IN THE 2008 ELECTION.
IN 1992, THE BUSH CAMPAIGN
ASKED THE BRITISH
CONSERVATIVES FOR DIRT ON BILL
CLINTON.
THOSE ARE JUST TWO EXAMPLES I
KNOW ABOUT PERSONALLY.
EVEN THE NEW YORK TIMES
EDITORIAL BOARD WHILE COMING
OUT FOR IMPEACHMENT ADMITS
TRUMP IS NOT ALONE IN THIS.
HAVE OTHER PRESIDENTS
CONDUCTED FOREIGN POLICY WITH
REELECTION IN MIND?
OF COURSE.
MORE RECENTLY THE DEMOCRATS
SEEM TO SPEND THEIR ENTIRE
TIME TRYING TO GET DIRT FROM
FOREIGN GOVERNMENTS.
LAST YEAR GROUP OF DEMOCRAT
SENATORS ASKED TO UKRAINIAN
OFFICIAL FOR DIRT ON TRUMP IN
2016 THE DEMOCRATS REPORTEDLY
TRIED TO GET DIRT ON TRUMP
FROM THE UKRAINIAN GOVERNMENT
ASKING FOR PAUL MANAFORT IT TO
BE INVESTIGATED, AND OF
COURSE, THE BIG ONE, HILLARY
CLINTON PAYING BRITISH AND
RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT SOURCES FOR
DIRT ON TRUMP.
NOW, THERE'S NO DOUBT
PRESIDENT TRUMP TALKED ABOUT
INVESTIGATING JOE BIDEN WITH
UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT.
THE DEMOCRATS AND THE
ESTABLISHMENT ARRESTING THEIR
CASE ON THE WORDS I WOULD LIKE
YOU TO DO US A FAVOR, AND HERE
WE COME TO THE CENTRAL
ASTONISHING BRAZEN DISHONESTY
OF THE DEMOCRATS AND EVERY
JOURNALIST WHO CLAIMS THERE'S
SOMETHING HERE ON FOREIGN
INTERFERENCE.
LET'S READ TOGETHER THE
TRANSCRIPT OF THE CALL.
I WOULD LIKE YOU TO DO US A
FAVOR BECAUSE OUR COUNTRY HAS
BEEN THROUGH A LOT AND UKRAINE
KNOWS A LOT ABOUT IT.
I WOULD LIKE YOU TO FIND OUT
WHAT HAPPENED WITH THIS WHOLE
SITUATION WITH UKRAINE, CROWD
STRIKE, THEY SAY UKRAINE HAS
IT.
THERE ARE THINGS THAT WENT ON,
THE WHOLE SITUATION.
WHEN HE ASKED FOR A FAVOR,
HE'S NOT ASKING ABOUT BIDEN,
HE WAS NOT ASKING FOR FUTURE
FOREIGN MEDDLING, HE WAS
ASKING ABOUT PAST FOREIGN
MEDDLING.
AGAIN, AS THE WALL STREET
JOURNAL NOTED, THERE ISN'T
NOTHING WRONG WITH ASKING A
FOREIGN HEAD OF STATE TO
INVESTIGATE MEDDLING IN U.S.
ELECTIONS.
LATER IN THE CALL,
CONVERSATION TURNS TO RUDY
GIULIANI AND ALLEGATIONS OF
WRONGDOING.
PRESIDENT TRUMP DOES INDEED
ENCOURAGE THE UKRAINIAN
PRESIDENT TO PURSUE THESE, BUT
GUESS WHO BRINGS IT UP.
NO, NOT PRESIDENT TRUMP, HE'S
THE ONE THAT INSTIGATES THEIR
BACK-AND-FORTH ABOUT THE BIDEN
SITUATION BY BRINGING UP
GIULIANI.
YOU CAN ARGUE THE PRESIDENT
LIKE TO BE WISER TO RESPOND BY
SAYING YOU KNOW WHAT, THAT'S
GETTING INTO POLITICAL PROBLEM
AND WE SHOULDN'T TALK ABOUT
IT, BUT THE IDEA THAT THIS
CALL IN THE SO-CALLED
WHISTLEBLOWER COMPLAINTS ABOUT
IT IS EVIDENCE THAT PRESIDENT
TRUMP ABUSED HIS OFFICE FOR
PERSONAL GAIN CALLED THE WORLD
LEADER TO ASK HIM TO GET DIRT
ON HIS OPPONENT, MEDDLED IN
OUR ELECTION AND USED A
AMERICAN MILITARY AID IS A
JOKE AND COMPLETE JOKE.
NOW WE HAVE EVIDENCE THAT IT'S
A JOKE.
THE FACT THAT THE DEMOCRATS
AND THEIR CO-CONSPIRATORS ARE
ALREADY MOVING AWAY FROM IT IS
A BASIS FOR IMPEACHMENT.
REMEMBER HOW THEY DROPPED
COLLUSION AND SWITCH TO
OBSTRUCTION?
IT'S HAPPENING AGAIN.
THEY KNOW THERE'S NO CASE ON
THE QUID PRO QUO SO GUESS
WHAT, NOW IT'S COVER-UP THE
ANTI- TRUMP BUREAUCRAT
ACTIVISTS, WHISTLEBLOWER
REVEALED THAT WHITE HOUSE
OFFICIALS PUT THE UKRAINE
TRANSCRIPT IN THE COMPUTER
SYSTEM DESIGNED FOR NATIONAL
SECURITY SEEKERS NOT FOR
DIPLOMATIC CAUSE.
LIKE SHEEP, IT'S THE COVER-UP
THAT GETS YOU, NOT THE CRIME.
ARE THEY SERIOUS?
FIRST AS WE'VE SHOWN YOU THERE
WAS NO CRIME.
SECOND DON'T THEY REMEMBER
THAT SHOCKINGLY SOME OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S EARLY PHONE
CALLS WITH WORLD LEADERS WERE
LEAKED.
WHY SHOULD ANYONE BE
SURPRISED, BUT FINALLY, THE
MOST OBVIOUS IDIOCY OF THE
CLAIM, THE WHITE HOUSE
PUBLISHED A CALL PROACTIVELY
BEFORE HE SUBPOENAED HER LEGAL
PROCESS THEY VOLUNTARILY
PUBLISH THE WHOLE THING.
SOME COVER-UP.
IT'S INCREDIBLE TO ME THAT ANY
SERIOUS PERSON COULD TAKE ANY
OF THIS SERIOUSLY, AND YET WE
SEE EVERY DEMOCRAT SPOUTING
THIS OBVIOUS NONSENSE.
ALMOST EVERY NEWS ANCHOR DOING
IT.
WE EVEN HEAR THAT IF THERE WAS
A SECRET BALLOT AT LEAST 30
REPUBLICAN SENATORS WOULD VOTE
TO CONVICT PRESIDENT TRUMP
FROM OFFICE.
THERE'S ONLY ONE EXPLANATION,
CLASS LOYALTY, RULING CLASS
LOYALTY FOR 50 YEARS A RULING
CLASS OF REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS, PERMANENT OFFICIALS
IN THE GOVERNMENT YOUR
ACCURACY WITH THEIR DONATIONS
HAVE RUN THE WORLD AND THEIR
INTEREST.
IT WAS BASED ON GLOBALISM.
THERE WERE TWO KEY
COMPONENTS.
FREE-TRADE AND OPEN BORDERS.
GLOBALISM MADE THE RULING
CLASS RICHER.
IF YOU ARE OPERATING ON A
GLOBAL NOT JUST NATIONAL SCALE
YOU CAN GET MUCH BIGGER AND
MAKE MUCH MORE MONEY IF YOU
OPEN YOUR BORDERS YOU CAN
IMPORT AS MANY NEW WORKERS AS
YOU WANT AND PAY THE REST OF
THEM SO YOUR PROFIT MARGINS
ARE LARGER.
IN 2016 AMERICA ELECTED A
PRESIDENT WHO STOOD AGAINST
ALL THAT AND STARTED TO TURN
IT AROUND.
THIS IS WHY THEY ARE DEFENDING
JOE BIDEN SO FEROCIOUSLY.
HE'S THE ABSOLUTE EPITOME OF
THE CORRECT RULING CLASS.
AS I SAID ON TWITTER LAST
WEEK, THE RULING CLASS ACT ALL
OUTRAGED ABOUT FOREIGN
INTERFERENCE IN OUR DEMOCRACY
THROUGH ELECTION MEDDLING.
THAT'S JUST NOT RIGHT.
THE RIGHT WAY TO DO IT IS TO
CUT OUT THE MIDDLEMAN.
DON'T WASTE TIME ON STUPID
ELECTIONS, JUST HAVE THE
FOREIGN COUNTRIES MEDDLED
DIRECTLY IN OUR GOVERNMENT.
FOREIGN GOVERNMENT INTERFERE
IN OUR DEMOCRACY EVERY DAY IN
WASHINGTON THROUGH ALL THE
SWAMPY TECHNIQUES WE'VE SHOWN
YOU OVER THE YEARS.
HIRING LAWYERS AND LOBBYISTS,
FUNDING THINK TANKS AND HAVING
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS RELATIVES
DIRECTLY ON THEIR PAYROLL.
WHAT TOTAL DISGUSTING
HYPOCRITES THEY ARE.
NANCY PELOSI TOOK MONEY FROM
SHADY COMPANIES IN UKRAINE.
CHUCK SCHUMER TOOK MONEY FROM
SAUDI ARABIA AND MEXICAN
GOVERNMENT.
[INAUDIBLE]
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S FORMER
DEFENSE SECRETARY JAMES MATTIS
NOW WORKS FOR THE SWAMPY :
GROUP WHICH BOASTS ABOUT
SHIPPING AMERICAN DEFENSE JOBS
OVERSEAS AND SELLING AMERICAN
MANUFACTURING FIRMS TO FOREIGN
COUNTRIES AND OF COURSE, JOE
BIDEN, FORGET ABOUT THE
UKRAINE CORRUPTION, THAT'S
NOTHING.
HE TOOK OVER A BILLION DOLLARS
IN BRIBES FROM THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT.
AMERICA'S NUMBER ONE ADVERSARY
IN THE FORM OF PAYMENTS IN
EXCHANGE FOR POLICY FAVORS.
SO, SPARE US THE SANCTIMONIOUS
ABOUT FOREIGN.
[INAUDIBLE]
YOU'VE BEEN SELLING AMERICA TO
THE HIGHEST FORM BETTER FOR
PERSONAL GAIN.
THIS IS GLOBALISM IN ACTION.
THIS IS WHAT AMERICA REJECTED
IN 2016 AND THE RULING CLASS
JUST CAN'T STAND IT.
THERE'S ONE MORE ASPECT TO
THIS.
ON TOP OF THE ECONOMIC
DEVASTATION THAT THEY BROUGHT
TO SO MANY HEARTLAND
COMMUNITIES, THERE IS A
CULTURAL CONDESCENSION,
ESPECIALLY ON THE LEFT WITH
THEIR INTOLERANCE AND HATE AND
WOKE MANIA.
THE RULING CLASS LOOK DOWN
THEIR NOSES AT THE VERY PEOPLE
WHO ARE THE VICTIMS OF THEIR
IDEA.
THEY SNEER AT THEIR FACE, THE
ESTABLISHMENT IS NOT
POLICY-BASED, IT'S CLASS
BASE.
THEY THINK HE'S VULGAR.
THEY MOCK HIM BECAUSE HE LIKES
MCDONALD'S.
THE POLICY, THE TURNAROUND ON
JOBS AND ESPECIALLY CHINA,
THEY MEAN NOTHING TO THEM.
THEY JUST HATE THIS
PRESIDENT.
THEY ARE PART OF THE RULING
CLASS.
THEY ARE DESPERATE TO FIT IN
AT WASHINGTON DINNER PARTIES.
THEY CRAVE APPROVAL.
THE CHALLENGE TO GLOBALISM,
THE CLASS PREJUDICE, THAT'S